and the Oscar goes to Tom Hanks in
Philadelphia
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here's what I know I could not be
standing here without that undying love
that was just song about by not Bruce
but Neil Young and I have that in a
lover that is so close to fine we should
all be able to experience such heaven
right here on earth I know also that I
should not be doing this I should not be
here but I am because of the union of
such filmmakers as Edie Saxon Ron nice
huan'er Christie's he attacked Fujimoto
Jonathan Demi who seems to have these
attached to his limbs with for every
actor that works with him of late and a
cast that includes Antonio Banderas who
who second to my lover is the only
person I would trade for and a cast that
includes many other people but the actor
who really put his film in an image at
risk and shown because of his integrity
mr. Denzel Washington who I really must
share this
I would not be standing here if it
weren't for two very important men in my
life sue sue that I haven't spoken with
in a while but I had the pleasure of
just the other evening mr. Raleigh
Farnsworth who was my high school drama
teacher who taught me that act well
depart there all the glory lies and one
of my classmates under mr. Farnsworth
mr. John Gill Kherson I mentor their
names because they are two of the finest
gay Americans two wonderful men that I
had the good fortune to be associated
with to fall under their inspiration at
such a young age which my babies could
have the same sort of teacher the same
sort of friends and there lies my
dilemma here tonight I know that by work
in this case is magnified by the fact
that the streets of heaven are too
crowded with angels we know their names
they number a thousand for each one of
the red ribbons that we wear here
tonight
they finally rest in the warm embrace of
the gracious creator of us all a healing
embrace that cools their fevers that
clears their skin and allows their eyes
to see the simple self-evident
common-sense truth that is made manifest
by the benevolent creator of us all and
was written down on paper by wise men
tolerant men in the city of Philadelphia
two hundred years ago God bless you all
God have mercy on us all and God bless
america
[Applause]